so this one's going to be for you on
kesayuchi
um
my rules are
every Strike should break or kill
there's
never a strike just for distraction
never a love tap
no minor to Major strikes
so these little pokes
no
those don't do anything
okay
how you strike with the weapon
it's going to follow the same mechanics
of how you strike with the hands it's
not two different things
okay
so on
castaguchi
it's always going to be through as many
planes as possible
so high width and depth
it's not simply a width strike
to get the height
it has to have a downwardness to it in
it
just like
yokelman
I'm not throwing yokumen
like this
it goes through his fight
from the side down but it is to
sensitively okay
and that means your power has to you
have to have anchored elbows my elbows
have to be anchored
if I bring my elbows up I don't have
power
okay
so I I won't hit him but I'll show my
elbow anchor on uh yokomen and I'll just
spur sit along his body so it doesn't
penetrate but you'll see the the weight
drop
my body hits with the downwardness okay
not not
something like this
it's only going to hurt their maybe
probably not okay
so the same thing on yoka man or
kesahuchi
never
here like this
always
here this way
okay
so when you do yoga man
the hands come up
and the hand is going to go down like
Showman
it's just my elbow comes in
that's all that happens
so showman elbow stays down
elbow comes in
don't come around
won't pop
home pop
same thing on Casa Richie
it's gonna be just like Sherman
but my elbow turns
Showman
my hands turn
okay you have your job
the power hand is the left hand
not the right hand
the left hand
this right hand aims into that but left
hand swings around
so I come around
not like this
don't make a big circle around your head
comes up to show men
and then I drop my elbows
man
drop my elbows
different
show man drop your elbows
at the end your hands should turn
no
turn your hand oh
left hand on top
right hand underneath
so close on my hands if you can
whoa
turn
not here
so if you step out
you can step out cross is
or you can step back
doesn't matter bye
forward
and then always
leave about two inches on the end
don't grab here
it fulcrums out your hand
here
and you can also hit with it
okay
so our drill is just offering
I come around
in the transition that's when you change
your hands
not on the strike
too late
can shifts
other hand grabs
[Applause]
in your stance
this back knee
is bent
no
drop drop
so you're grounded
here not not here
on your base
get on this face
okay
all right let's try the drunk here uh
the back foot's the power foot the back
foot between the back foot
okay
so you don't want to hit the weapon with
the other foot still in there
okay so my foot is going to move with
the Joe so the Joe's coming around and
the back foot moves with it
they landed they say hit and land at the
same time not hit
then foot
and not foot
okay
it's at that same time
oh
you see okay try it again and your hands
come together
your hands come together
the right hand moves back okay
as you go
don't grab to here
grab one to two inches
right hand comes back
don't keep them apart
and you're keeping them apart
around
slides gonna slide
slides down okay